It's my pleasure to welcome to the program
today.
Ask for Taylor, who is an author and documentary
filmmaker.
She's the director of the film.
What is democracy?
And also author of the book democracy may
not exist, but we'll miss it when it's gone.
Uh, great to talk to you.
I appreciate it.
Hey, thanks for having me.
So we've had conversations before, um, what
democracy, uh, is, should be and could be.
And one of the conversations that often ends
up happening between, uh, the audience, uh,
and me after those interviews are these questions
about, um, is direct democracy re, uh, really
the only type of democracy that we should
be going for and questions like that.
And I find that a little bit less interesting
than something you're dealing with, which
is the idea of is it really democracy?
If there is dark money, if there is disproportionate
power by Kleptocrats and corporations and
peoples in p people in positions of power,
et cetera.
So to kind of start the conversation, has
there ever been a democracy?
And that could be a, uh, however we choose
to define it, that was not in some way influenced
by those forces, uh, by which many modern
Western democracies are influenced today.
I think it's an interesting question.
I mean, I've certainly been involved in those
debates you just laid out.
Right?
You know, is, is the only real democracy direct
and, and not, you know, not using structures
of representation and, and so, um, that influences
a bit of, of the work I'm doing.
But I tried to, uh, ask a different kind of
question.
Actually I wanted to shift perspective and
to s to look at democracy as a process, as
an ongoing project.
And it kind of ideal that we're reaching towards.
And one of the consistent things that has
thwarted, uh, people in their democratic aspirations
has been the problem of economic inequality.
And this goes all the way back to ancient
Greece.
So, you know, the ancient Athenians didn't
invent the practice of democracy, but they
gave us the word, uh, which comes down to
Deimos and Kratos.
The people hold power or rule.
And even in those early days, which, you know,
they didn't have a system that you could describe
as capitalism, right?
They didn't have a modern industrial economy
like, like we do.
But nonetheless, they were very attuned to
the fact that any qualities of wealth would
subvert democracy.
And in fact, in the republic, which is, you
know, the famous anti-democratic text by Plato,
um, where he famously warns that democracy
devolves into tyranny.
He says very clearly that the underlying problem
is that the divide between the rich and the
poor grows to the point where it breaks the
city into where the rich want to get richer.
And so they put poor people into debt and
the poor can't live anymore.
Um, and so that this creates conflict and
leads to the rise of demagogues and what we
would consider populism in today's terms.
So I think with the problem of economic inequality
as something democracies have to wrestle with,
and it creates all sorts of problems for the
way our political system is structured today.
It, in my book, in, in, in the framing I use,
what I say is that there are these inherent
tensions in democracy there.
Why democracy is, is because it involves contradictory
elements, right?
So the local and the global and the question
of who's in and who's out.
And, uh, the question, how to balance the
needs of the present with the future, but
intense inequality, economic inequality just
makes those tensions almost, you know, unbearable
and really, um, uh, makes exacerbates, uh,
problems that we have to negotiate no matter
what.
Yeah, I, um, when I, I'm reminded of when
I read Jared diamond's book, guns, germs and
steel, and in it he talks about, I think he
divides, um, uh, people as, as potentially
organizing in four different ways going from
I think it's individual villages, like groups
of families, relatively small.
Um, and maybe the second one is tribes then
fiefdoms and then more sort of like nation
states or something closer to what we have
today.
Uh, and once you get to the fiefdoms and the
nation states, it's really difficult to imagine
circumstances in which there is not going
to be some inequality, either be it economic
or in terms of cultural power, which often
comes from disproportionate economic power.
Now there will be those who will hear us talking
and they'll say, no, you guys are missing
the reality that this is really an economic
conversation about socialism versus capitalism.
And that you can have a democracy that is
far more equal, if not totally equal, if you
simply change your system of government to
one of socialism.
But I actually think it's more complicated
than that.
I'm curious to hear what you think about it.
Well, you know, in the preface to the book
and throughout, I, I, you know, invoke, um,
the socialist project, right?
Because I think Socialists have played an
incredibly powerful role in, in, in advancing
democracy as we know it today.
I mean, they were, they pushed for, for suffrage,
for civil rights, all sorts of things.
Um, I, my, my point is that even in a system
of economic egalitarianism, right?
So even if we were able to close the gap between
the rich and the poor between owners and workers,
right?
And, and I personally have, I have an imagination
that allows me to imagine that.
I mean, just like a, a hundred years ago,
someone might say, hey, masters and slaves.
That's just natural.
That's how it always is.
You know, now we say, hey, there's makers
and takers.
There's rich and poor.
That's how it always is.
I personally can imagine a world where we've
closed that gap because we know that we know
some countries have far less, uh, wild decrees
of any quality than the United States today.
So, you know, I think we could do a lot to,
um, to lift people up and bring other people
down to a sane level.
We don't need a world where we don't need
a country where three billionaires have as
much wealth as half of the, uh, population.
Uh, and so the thing I'm trying to say is
that the democracy part is actually the challenging
bit because even in a world we might call
socialist or in an economy that that is not
capitalism as we know it, we'd still have
to balance these factors.
We'd still have to figure out, well, when
is cordial legitimate or when can people choose,
right?
Uh, when do we, um, marshaled the, uh, expertise
of that only a few people have?
And when do we, um, uh, you know, harness
public opinion, right?
When, how do we balance the needs of people
who live today with people who have not yet
been born?
So the book and that I think when we look
at things that way, we can say, okay, well
democracy is something that you know, is a
constant negotiation.
We have to constantly reinvent it.
We have to constantly think of new, well,
who is the people and how do they role?
Um, and so I don't think that, you know, socialism
is this magic word that would solve all of
our problems.
My attitude is that actually if we had a more
economically fair system, if we had a system
where we finally had, you know, politically
quality, we were where we understood women
are equals of men and black people are equal
to white people.
And you know, people without papers are equal
to people with papers.
If we finally had that kind of, um, equality
that democracy actually requires and the economic
equality to support that political equality,
then we'd actually get to have really, really
interesting democratic debates.
Because then we'd have to think about things
like, well, how do we have control?
Do we have communities that have, say over
the decisions that affect them, that have
influence over the decisions that affect their
lives, while also taking into account the
broader world, right?
How do we balance the needs of, uh, the present
and those who are not yet born, right?
That's the problem of climate change.
So I think that, um, democracy is always going
to be, it's always going to be difficult.
Um, and, but hopefully those challenges will
just get more interesting.
Yeah.
In thinking about the broader world, I mean,
I hesitate to talk about the, anytime you
introduce the term, what is natural?
I mean, remember the, around the gay marriage
debate, how problematic this concept of what,
what is natural a was, but to think at least
hypothetically for a moment, is the idea of
people being democratic, unnatural or an unnatural
idea.
When we think back to humans, like in a state
of nature, hypothetically.
So when you think about how humans interact
at some of those smaller scales in bands of
a few families is what might work or not work.
They're not necessarily relatable or translatable
to populations of millions or even hundreds
of millions of people as we now have in some
of the larger countries.
That's a loaded question given the history
of political philosophy, right?
Which is always invoked the state of nature,
this hypothetical, a situation where, you
know, people were either a warring and defensive
in a hobsy incense or actually living in peace
without, um, private property in a [inaudible]
sense.
Say, I'm curious about this, but I'm wondering
if it's even the right question to be.
Yeah, I live in question.
I think it's, you know, I think, well, it's
interesting to me the way, you know, political
philosophy, um, promotes different ideologies
and, and it comes in moments of political
rupture and it helps people think through
the problems of their day.
I would frame things differently.
I mean, I think if you look at human history,
there's all this contradictory evidence, right?
The history of democracy is, you know, a history
of colonial conquest imperialism.
I mean, it's, it's, we in a nation that calls
itself the land of freedom that was founded
on the ultimate form of unfreedom slavery.
Um, you know, people have made really terrible
choices in the, in, uh, in the past, but,
you know, then you can also look back at human
history, democratic history and see that there
are all sorts of wonderful advances, right?
That people have, um, had solidarity, they've
set up for each other.
That actually this circle of inclusion is,
you know, expanding and if it's, it's, um,
imperfect and, and, um, and sometimes progress
goes into reverse.
So I, I think the jury is still out and that
we shouldn't extrapolate too much from sort
of, you know, some idea of a state of nature.
I, I liked it from the question actually,
to go back to Rousseau in terms of what was
called the founding paradox and as this founding
paradox of political philosophy, and it's
how do you make a democratic people out of
an undemocratic people.
And you know, if we don't naturally inclined
towards, you know, democracy especially in,
uh, a modern industrial, uh, you know, global
system, like the one we live in, we have to
do is we have to create the conditions for
us to be democratic through culture, through
education, through organizations of solidarity.
We have to nurture a democratic ethos.
And that's our challenge I think, as, as part
of the many, as part of regular, you know,
as part of a community of regular people.
I think we also live in a system where the
powerful have exactly the opposite agenda.
What they want to do is create an undemocratic
people out of a democratically spirited people.
So that's why, you know, famously in the late
sixties, you know, Samuel Huntington and others
said there was a crisis of democracy when,
when youth were revolting and, and, um, and
there was too much sort of labor unrest, what
they were like, oh no, there's, you know,
for, for elites, when there's too much democracy,
it's a crisis.
They want people to become more undemocratic,
more complacent.
So, you know, I think we are, we're certainly
standing in a moment where there's a kind
of, um, democratic inclusion that, that people,
um, not that long ago would have thought was,
you know, impossible.
Right?
I mean, people said, you know, women were
totally incapable of, of rational in judgment
and participation and needed to have, you
know, their husband speak for them.
So we don't know what's possible.
Um, and I think invoking human nature is,
yeah, often, uh, not the best way to go.
How can we interpret in thinking about this
issue, what we now know to be a reality that
often democracies can make the wrong choices
or at least uninformed choices or sometimes
ignorant choices or whatever the case may
be.
And whether we apply it to the current administration
or whatever else, it doesn't really matter.
But conceptually, I mean, even going back,
uh, to, to some of the older teachings that
you cite in your work, um, there is this problem
where oftentimes the, the populace, uh, of
the more populous countries will have uprisings
or, um, social social moves or changes that
lead to bad decisions being made within the
system.
How should we think about that more broadly?
At a political philosophy level?
Yeah, I mean, I think it's a risk that we
have to take.
I would never argue that democracy isn't risky.
The Deimos can make bad choices, but I think
just, you know, again, just as we might say,
okay, there's all this evidence that we can't
trust the Deimos that they are, this unruly
mob played a warned of, you know, that the
democracy marginalizes the wise and the virtuous,
which is what he said in the republic.
And we also have to say the best ideas about
democracy came from people came from people
who were excluded, right?
When women said we should be included as equal
citizens.
They were outside the community, outside the
political community, ideas about what democracy
could be, have always come from the margins
from oppressant and outsiders.
And the other thing is that, you know, we've,
we've tried technocracy that's sort of been
what we've, the system, you know, that's some
people talk about, uh, neoliberal capitalism
is one where the technocrats rule, right?
They'll sort of put the experts in charge
and, and they'll make decisions.
And, you know, we've, what we've had is a,
uh, an intense, you know, escalation in terms
of the concentration of wealth.
We've had, um, you know, a systems emerge
that are too big to fail except the fact they
can fail.
What we're facing is a climate crisis that
even though the science says this is going
to be devastated and in fact, it already is
devastating for, for 'em communities, climate
change is happening now.
You know, we, we seem unable to stop it.
So, you know, putting experts in charge, um,
you know, uh, and demand, you know, diminishing
the power of the people hasn't worked either.
So that's where I think, um, we have to, again,
create structures where people can, can become
more informed.
This is why education is so central to, to
the democratic project.
Um, we also have to create a media ecosystem
that has positive incentives.
Before this book, I wrote a book called the
People's platform about the political economy
of the Internet and how, you know, so much.
The problem with it is that the incentives
are all towards clickbait and fast turning
content because, you know, it's the, the business
model is advertising is, is, um, is data collection,
right?
So, you know, we're, we are, we're, we have
to address these sort of underlying economic
arrangements that shape our culture and in,
and, you know, distort our democracy.
So we have to be holistic and, and have a
complicated analysis.
But I don't think the, um, I don't think we
can, can right off the people, especially
because working class people have been, have
been, again, at the forefront of pushing for
things like public education, pushing for
the right to be, not just, uh, workers, but,
uh, part of, part of a philosophical public,
right.
That, um, that is, is essential to democracy
as soon as my audience has been hearing for
the last month in particular.
Um, we really should do what we can to separate
the media landscape from a dependence on ad
revenue because it does, I totally agree the
wrong incentives fundamentally.
And people had this fight.
People had this fight with, you know, television.
We had the fight with radio.
This is where we're not in unprecedented territory,
right?
People said the media landscape is being distorted
by these incentives and they push for public
television.
They pushed for controls on advertising.
We need to do the same.
And in the digital sphere,
completely agree.
We have been speaking with Astra Taylor who
was an author and documentary filmmaker, the
Dura.
She is the director of the film.
What is democracy and author of the book?
Democracy may not exist.
Well, we'll miss it when it's gone.
Uh, so great to talk to you today.
Hey, thanks for having me on